hey siri are there gonna be any hardware
announcements at wwdc today so i'd like
to take a moment to briefly address this
question
no
of course not
[Applause]
[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and this
year just like every year we get apples
wwdc now being a worldwide developer
conference this is not like an iphone
launch this isn't like a hardware
product launch or anything like that
this is mainly just apple talking to
developers about software so you know
watch os mac os
ios all that good stuff but like every
year we hope for like some nuggets just
a little bit of hardware to be thrown in
there like i think last year at this we
got the sneak peek of the imac pro and
we got homepod but we're out here for
2018 and the main keynote has come and
gone and there is zero new hardware for
this event so this is all software i
already kind of gave my sort of first
impressions and ranted live on twitter
but for the sake of putting everything
in one place or in case you missed it
and don't want to watch the three-hour
keynote this is the top five
announcements of wwdc 2018. so putting
them in order is really easy number five
is the most boring one apple tv no
offense to apple tv but basically tv os
just got a couple little minor updates
nothing groundbreaking they got uh dolby
atmos support for better surround sound
audio they also added some live sports
and news channels as a bonus they tossed
in a couple new video screen savers
which are already majestic to begin with
but they have some new ones that were
shot from the international space
station so from earth looking down in
beautiful 4k hdr they look magnificent
so that's really cool to see i still
have to bring up though that you can't
watch youtube in 4k
on the apple tv 4k as beautiful as those
new international space station videos
are
that would have been an awesome thing to
see i know there's a sort of a stalemate
there between google and apple but
frustrating anyway number four is
augmented reality and this actually felt
like a pretty big push from apple this
year uh especially in ios of just seeing
ar all over the place they announced a
new file format called usdx which
basically it already has support from
the adobe cloud and it's a way for
sharing ar experiences so you can embed
ar experiences you can share them you
can put them in apps put them in
websites there's a bunch more ar kit
improvements from last year so they made
some major strides it's already at 2.0
and they announced a new app which is
it's not going to come default with ios
called the measure app and it's
literally an augmented reality ruler
just lets you point your camera at
things and measure them on the screen
it's what we've all been waiting for for
a while actually a lot of us weren't
waiting for it was kind of a thing in
the app store already r.i.p to all those
apps but i thought it was pretty cool
just literally dragging along lines in
real life getting measurements of how
long they are and how tall things are
i'm definitely going to start measuring
how tall people and buildings and all
the random things are with this seems
really cool and then possibly the most
technically impressive use of ar that
they showed would be simultaneous
sharing of an ar experience between two
devices at the same time
that's like the least sexy way of
explaining that but you already know
what ar looks like it's mixed reality
you can have two different devices
looking at two different angles of the
same thing at the same time and
interacting with it and the demo they
did on stage was pretty incredible it
was just with legos but there's a whole
lot going on i also got to try a demo of
this in an app basically it was a
slingshot game and the game was built
around this mini world of blocks that
people only looking at the ipads can see
but they're running around slingshotting
things at each other and knocking down
towers it was just kind of funny to see
people getting so enthusiastic running
around with ipads around an empty wooden
table but honestly this is a really
really big step forward for ar hopefully
multiple devices can come to the same
experience at once a lot going on so
it's cool to see apple push this forward
so the number three is the apple watch i
don't wear mine all the time but it got
some nifty improvements with watch os
five that's what i call it nifty
improvements so there's some new
activity sharing features for competing
with or against your friends with
workouts and things like that there's
new workout types for things like yoga i
think outdoor running and a couple other
things like that were involved and then
also there's automatic workout detection
in case you started a workout but then
forgot to start the workout on the watch
and you want to get credit for that
it'll kind of know when you started
there's also a new walkie-talkie mode
which they showed if you want a
walkie-talkie someone on your watch
instead of just calling them
i don't know if i would use that but
some people were into it but there's
some other things like the podcast app
coming to the watch which is useful uh
and also the fact that you can raise to
talk so instead of saying hey siri every
time you raise it up it'll just detect
when you raise it up know that you're
talking to it and you can just start
your command hey what's the weather hey
what's the sports scores so that's
pretty nifty but overall yeah it's just
a collection of useful new features
that's that's watch os five but then we
get to the big stuff number two
is the exciting new mac os mojave so
that's the name of the new and again
free upgrade for mac os named after the
mojave desert
totally cool with me i like the name and
the biggest coolest feature if you'd
asked me by far would be the addition of
dark mode dark mode in mojave is sweet
it's not just turning the menus dark
like you can already do that but it's
turning everything dark it's super
thorough it's the finder it's the
background of apps it's the menus it's
the dock it's everything throughout
that's gonna look super sick on the
space gray imac pro i am super excited
for this sidenote they should also uh
probably make an ios
dark mode which would be sweet now that
they have oleds especially as well on
the iphone 10 ios dark mode anyway i
really like dark mode on mac os and i'm
looking forward to using it then there
was a couple other things like the mac
app store redesign i can't believe how
long it took them to do that it looked
super old but that's coming to the new
version of mac os and there's also now
voice memos stocks
news and even the home app all these
things that are actually coming from ios
and it sort of signaled the beginning of
a lot of crossover well not crossover
it's mainly just ios apps coming to that
mac experience so people who develop ios
apps will only have to add a couple of
lines of code to build and bring that
entire experience to the mac i think
that'll bolster the mac app store a lot
that seems like their goal with that but
the beginning of that was those couple
apps that are launching and then one of
the most liked new features is called
desktop stacks this is for people who
have a messy desktop which isn't me i
have a really clean pristine desktop
it's rare for me to have more than like
four things on my desktop but if your
desktop is a mess you can have it
automatically organized basically
arranged in stacks by file type or
whatever you want so if you're dealing
with a lot of clutter this can
definitely help it look a lot better and
then number one i wasn't even going to
make this number one but because of all
the crowd pleasing features they ended
up adding to it it is up at the top and
that is ios 12. the best thing at wwdc
this year was all the new ios 12
features it's actually out already in
beta so people are still currently
actively discovering new features with
it that weren't even announced on stage
maybe leave a thumbs up if you want to
see like a full video dedicated to the
new ios features kind of like i've done
with android in the past but there was a
lot of good stuff first of all they say
they're doubling down on performance
that was the number one thing they gave
so this is going to be a big update
that's going to go all the way back to
iphone 5s so many many years of older
devices are going to get this that's
what apple can do so they concentrate on
things like faster animations faster
loading and reloading and making things
work and be responsive and i'll never be
against that that's great to see and
then they announced grouped
notifications
are finally coming to ios
finally
finally i mean we've just been waiting
for this forever i mean obviously ios
notifications right now big complaint i
mentioned this or right before the
keynote if you have scrolled through ios
notifications it's just a fire hose of
redundant garbage like i don't need all
of that so what they showed on stage was
pretty promising ios notifications from
the same app get stacked together so you
can address them all in one place
they're organized they're clear-cut
certain ones you can keep you can swipe
away groups of them at a time it's
finally appeared to catch up to android
in this way from the miles behind it's
been for so long in fact i'm pretty sure
i'm gonna put ios 12 on my new iphone
like right after this video just for
this feature and then they also
announced group facetime
finally there's another thing people who
use facetime really like it and use it a
lot now you can do group facetime video
calls so it's basically this rolodex
style group chat you can have up to 32
people in one at once
and it's just the same video call that's
pretty insane basically whoever's
talking their photo moves to the top and
it gets bigger i don't think i'll ever
have 30 people in one chat but it'll be
cool to have three or four people who
video chat a lot using this that was
another huge crowd favorite and then
while the writer even siri got some
improvements it wasn't nearly enough
improvements to catch up to google
assistant i think it's still way behind
but it did get a useful feature called
shortcuts so what this is going to let
you do is connect a certain in-app
action or in-app shortcut to a custom
command that you make in the shortcuts
app or even a string of these commands
so you can say hey siri heading home
just because you made that up and in the
app you can tell it to
set your thermostat to 70 degrees at
home open your navigation app to take
the best route through traffic text your
roommate your eta home and open spotify
and start playing music in the car all
of that just by saying
one phrase you can build that in series
shortcuts that's definitely useful it's
kind of the the one thing bixby had
going for it for samsung
so
sorry bixby sorry samsung oh and
actually speaking of samsung
another thing animoji got an upgrade
this is another thing i played with
there is a new tongue detection and a
couple new animals like a t-rex and a
ghost emoji so if you're waiting for new
ones now you have them but what's really
making headlines already is
memoji momoji meme
momoji memoji memo memo mimoji so it'll
let you make a custom animoji that looks
exactly like you it's not going to look
at your picture and make one for you
like samsung did it's actually just
letting you build your own so i tossed
one together and played around with it
and it's exactly what you'd expect it's
like a cartoon version of yourself that
you can spend a lot of time getting the
details exactly right on if you really
want to and then they talked about
tongue detection being a big deal and
that is true you can now stick out your
tongue and it gets as crazy as you want
there but i actually found the eye
tracking to be super realistic that's
what really sold it for me you didn't
really have eyes on previous animojis it
was just kind of a beady black dot
pretty impressive is the actual turning
of the eye inside the head without your
head moving not gonna lie so again sorry
samsung and sorry ar emoji but yeah
those are the keystone like huge things
for ios you also now get animoji in
facetime you also get a bunch of
improvements to search and suggested
search and things like that in the
photos app and there's also now the
ability to sort of track your overall
use of your phone and maybe decide if
you want to cut down on some things or
drop the addiction of certain apps by
restricting the amount of time you spend
in it that's useful so yeah just
generally a lot of improvements under
the hood a couple new really big useful
features that's what's new in ios 12.
it's not a whole lot of design stuff
it's gonna look the same but the
features are new but that is it that is
everything you need to know about what
went down at wwdc
2018 out here in california feel free to
share this video with anyone you think
may be interested maybe you know someone
who is dying to get facetime video chat
going and let me know what your favorite
feature is maybe you agree with my list
maybe you don't maybe have a different
favorite
either way
thanks for watching
talk to you in the next one peace
you